the best moment to go fishing is
early
in the morning it starts in life begins
and then I am alone alone on the
water with the animals that weigh about a thousand
kilos listening to you oostduinkerke is the
last place in the world but that there is
still being moored with horses and the sea
[Music]
I'm stefan and anke and I'm 4 a
couple the fishes in our thinking and
basic trek park is not natural
to learn from going in the sea
well look at the fishes is about  a
year that is necessary one that there is a park
that can
and then I hear horse eat that he
becomes to a trust in your app poor
trust in you
and then you must accompany a good in the
sea
[Music]
wedeven about three o'clock
it is  still we don't have to go that
deep we have to look for where the
shrimps are but usually that is
about the chest height of the
horse
they are about
look what a net is the small
shrimps through the sieve trend towards the
small ones  terrain the seas if they can
grow that there had not been lost
the tradition exist hear of the thirteen
fourteen that one
and if we have a lämmle to remain it
must all those on the same tradition and
the year 9 if I know on that partner
is true  the differences in which stood warm
and which was designed another de panne
miep
and then now there are display pressure 19
horse fishermen and for deadly are the
three young people and training them
including my son
came about five years I think then
succeed
the first opinion of  my daddy and ot and
i were immediately better
discover for so much fun that's
why life is always not up
to it is there is no problem for me
we are with nature
or hear it with the people of the coast
that is part of it  now
if you think of us clap
may people who think from the other side of the
world
and speak of us is the end
couple the rest physio the co2 the culture and
I thought very proud of I am very
traffic jam
[Music]
[  Applause]